my father was the OG I was raised by
probably the best father on Earth I
really genuinely but he wasn't around
but a father doesn't have to be around
this is a big
machine along
the idea that a father needs to sit
around like a second mother to make a
child healthy is a fallacy in fact I'd
say it's detrimental to the child I see
all these dudes out here that have a kid
and they basically become mother number
two why the mother keeps the Child Alive
as a father it's your job to be
impactful you need to guide you need to
be a role model you need to be a
superhuman everyone should look at their
father like a superhero that's what you
should genuinely view them as it's hard
to be a superhero if you're home every
day arguing with your wife changing
diapers that's not what man should do a
man should Rock up teach lessons be
impactful and it's more about quality as
opposed to quantity of time I saw my dad
once a month
he was out on the streets he was pimping
hustling my father was a chess
Grandmaster he's traveling the world
playing chess he hit all his girls he's
doing whatever he's doing when he came
home it was an impactful time